sanctions imposed today are intended to
convince putin to change course and
avoid what the u.s president calls the
worst case scenario our crystal
gomencing just crossed the ukrainian
border into poland tonight crystal what
are you hearing from people in the
region
donna ukrainian leaders have been
waiting for tough sanctions to be
applied to russia the hope was that they
would have come sooner however if they
are tough enough and enough countries
act together they could limit how far
russia advances into ukraine as for the
mood of the people they almost seem more
united now
not only in levies where we've just come
from but keeve as well they are
determined to keep up with their regular
life pushing away any notion of panic or
fear
if something will start well i'm too old
to fight but at least i'm still capable
to carry ammo but for people with
somewhere else to go it's hard to quiet
voices outside of the country an
international medical student tells us
his family is urging him to return to
india my parents are very very much
panicked
they always call come come and
[Music]
see your parents back home yeah don't
want you to be in ukraine yeah yeah what
did they say to you
they only see the news channels and all
and they panic very much and how do you
feel
not so much panic but due to my parent
issues i have to go india foreigners are
often reminded that ukrainians have been
engaged in an ongoing war in the east
for the past eight years they say that
ukraine is a very large country and
until the conflict is at their doorstep
they refuse to be paralyzed by fear
donna
crystal command singh thanks well
canada's position mirrors that of the
u.s that the russian invasion of ukraine
has started it is the deputy prime
minister said today a test of our
resolve and that of our allies mercedes
stephenson has canada's reaction to all
of this mercedes
donna the tone here in the nation's
capital urgent and dire from the prime
minister and the top ministers from his
cabinet who were gathered around him
tonight during a press conference take a
listen to what prime minister justin
trudeau and deputy prime minister
christopher freeland had to say about
the situation in ukraine
canada and our allies will defend
democracy we are taking these actions
today to stand against authoritarianism
the people of ukraine
like all people must be free to
determine their own future
this is an attempt
to replace that rules-based
international order with a world in
which might makes right
where the great powers have the
authority to redraw the borders
dictate the foreign policies and control
the governments
of sovereign democracies
donna you could really feel the weight
there of the potential for a global
crisis here that the government was
underlining canada taking action falling
in line with what the united states has
done in terms of announcing sanctions
against russia those sanctions include
banning canadians from dealing
financially with the independent states
sanctioning the russian parliamentarians
who voted in favor of recognizing those
states banning canadians from purchasing
russian sovereign debt as well as
putting sanctions on two state-backed
russian banks and officials say that
this will escalate further if necessary
this is just the first round not
considered the invasion round if russia
goes further the sanctions will get
worse and could include canadian exports
mercedes canada is moving additional
troops to the region what can you tell
us about that
so 460 additional troops scheduled to go
in that includes a frigate a plane that
can detect submarines and do
intelligence on land as well as a
battery of artillery troops that's 120
people but it will take a month to
mobilize that last one
so certainly some concerns about both
the numbers being sent and how quickly
canada is capable of actually moving
donna
all right mercedes stevenson in ottawa
thanks